what's exam that both it was the impact
of his political conception on the
emerging political polish opposition to
they compose communist regime almost all
serious polish opposition groups to
emerge since the 1960's and in the 1970s
and 1980s not only accepted the gather
it's Mira chaska strategic program for
Poland but also for you today dear Rouge
and ridgeway Nia I will not enumerate
all them because the audit for this
audience it is certainly not necessary
because it is well acquainted with the
individual groups however I should say
that during my many suit that travels
academic travels to Poland I had been in
contact with these groups and I can
attest to this connection also I would
like to add in the something which
was already mentioned professor season
that even the Polish officially approved
historiography of that period was on in
general and email or even got to such
politically sensitive issues as Ukraine
definitely on a much higher level both
methodologically and in antique valiant
terms then Soviet history up in the
1970s and 80s it was ranked quite high
in by knowledgeable historians as the
fifth after American French German and
British and in spite of effective
service ideological surveillance they
existed various schools of thought in
Polish history yoga t2 which I can
attest as a coordinator
three conferences of Polish and American
destroyed Boleyn was the only country in
the Soviet bloc aside from the Soviet
Union in which some forms of you gaining
studies existed and a group of serious
professional historians work on approved
historical topics even authors of the
notoriously political of notoriously
political books written for instance by
security officials like draw at full
dooney cons I was asked by dr. name ski
about this book last night hey open by
chestnut and shut up and the scandalous
writings of Buddhist were clues provided
factual material which was not which was
not mentioned in Soviet Ukrainian or
Soviet history ography in general at
that time especially the orthodontic on
which dealt with this military struggle
against the Ukrainian insurgent army
between the gate hit in the Ukrainian
diaspora by being published in a pirated
edition by one of the Hoopa that an
association and sold in three thousand
copies in the diaspora in Poland several
weeks after its publication is was taken
of the shelves upon intervention of
Soviet authorities Poland was the only
time in the sky cafe which allowed a
kettle at University to function as an
institution in the system of higher
education it's Institute of his sin tell
you of under the directorship of the
edge report for Joss tea together with
the foundation of Pope John Paul the
second and the Lipinski is European
Research Institute as well as the other
action in the between E&D astra
institution organized the first
historical scholarly conference below
ashley 20 I Poland Ukraine the formation
of historical and cultural traditions in
its central europe in early may of
nineteen ninety that in which permanent
you payin scholars from you think
before the official proclamation of
Ukrainian sovereignty in July of 90 of
the same here and in the back